ah qui l'a dit j'étais rousse ronde
myope avec des lunettes à triple foyers
Mylène Farmer moi je pense à Mylène sur
toutes les rousses
que j'adore évidemment
c'est un vrai sondage côté Marlène
Jobert quand même
elle a aussi dit qu'elle a porté un
énorme appareil pendant des années donc
elle était elle se sentait pas hyper
jolie mais que pour se faire remarquer
parce que personne n'a regardé comme
elle avait envie l'âge de 8 ans elle
portait des grosses lunettes le
secrétaire façon
mais bébé ça s'appelle adolescence moi
je faisais 67 kg j'étais double et
grichons je mettais deux t-shirts l'un
sur l'autre pour essayer de paraître
plus musclé bah si donc je m'habiller en
Bibendum Michelin pourquoi mais quand il
fait des habitants et bien qu'il restait
une allumette donc effectivement elle a
dit elle évoque son rapport au physique
adolescente elle avait pas toutes les
chances de ce côté quand on est enfant
on a aucune envie de se démarquer et
avec ça on ne voyait que moi
potentiellement j'avais tout pour
devenir le souffre-douleur de l'école
voilà tout est là j'ai fait le clown
j'ai les cheveux en brosse j'ai porté
des lunettes de secrétaire des années 50
totalement improbable à 8 ans qui
t'aiment pas à ne pas passer inaperçu
donc voilà donc je me suis construite
comme la moche rigolote et ça a mis des
années avant qu'on me repère c'est
amusant quand même il faut savoir que
quand et aujourd'hui on la trouve
magnifique très belle et elle est passée
à autre chose là c'est il y a eu un gros
changement alors faut dire aussi on va
être très honnête faut dire aussi que
faut arrêter de mentir le succès et
l'argent ça aide quand vous regardez la
boum vous prenez Sophie Marceau et tous
les acteurs autour
et son nez la même année ils ont pas la
même gueule
Florence Foresti là dans son dernier
spectacle elle disait vous prenez
Vincent Cassel en vrai c'est pas Vincent
Cassel bon c'est pas c'est pas génial
si tu manges pas bio si tu as pas un
petit peu de de médecine esthétique si
t'as pas un peu d'argent pour tout ça
syndrome du vilain petit canard il y a
beaucoup d'enfants qui est vraiment pas
gâté par la nature et qui deviennent de
très beaux adultes il y a aussi
l'inverse alors c'est un témoignage bah
oui oui moi je connais plein d'enfants
alors